how's it goin breasts money
welcome to harmful scrap he has a really
hard way I don't even know what I'm
talking about
let's just get started I don't lie we
have been waiting for amnesia custom
stories like what makes the Musha I knew
that company's down sorry here it is you
should be happier there we go more more
okay that okay that's enough stop it
you're creeping me out
I'm just kidding alright alright so I
wanted playing the piano if you remember
from the original a Mesa basically the
monster is playing the piano but I'm
like how the hell is he playing with
those hands
how does he masturbate without hands
that's another question you could ask
yourself if you want to hey hey we meet
again my dear friend alright how you
doing today how you doing Russ Nia Misha
get prompt all right Justin my name is
Justin I might as well kill myself let
see me but you have passed out before so
I had no chance to take goodbyes we'll
meet up later and I heard strange noises
from your basement before you should
check out for rats and something before
you make a trip to in my house I used
your home key to lock the door and when
you [ __ ] I'll give it to you when we
meet again do you know anything about a
lovely absolutely lovely and I pity be
careful I don't trust this place I don't
know who's playing the piano sure
telling Justin Bieber what oh I got a
key alright I used a key and then we go
be careful baby I don't trust this place
okay every time I take it slow then
daddy fire this was hard I swear to God
in for that now Petey I love you give me
a kiss I can't kiss a rock
are you ridiculous okay
I would a kiss a rock she's crazy I
think she's I don't know like her oh oh
but is it throwing notes now I don't
like it boss did you have something to
do with this only throw a note to me you
should read it pity I am about ood don't
be ridiculous
hey gods where are you Justin I've been
looking for you you are not at home I've
look inside you're put out of every
single room no also a good reminder
there's something strange about your
basement
it feels are they talking about it but
it feels like it comes closer as I write
this note you will read it I locked your
basement
I locked my but I can understand having
this feeling something could backstab me
any seconds I'm sorry to say but the key
broke in the process god damn you yawn
alright so I guess we got to go there
but we wrote something down John said
the basement was locked
what got damaged we had to find a key
then pee but be careful I don't trust it
he was playing the piano like a BA us
alright I'll put you down here and then
we're gonna loot [ __ ] like about
goddamnit
oh wait nevermind nevermind I'll find
later Ned Ned anonym boats Abby's new
that piano was a [ __ ] I was gonna play
a dowel nevermind or fan someone like
sing with miss about it like yeah I mean
nothing but they'll be asked it's like
the best you got
whatever I am French French people don't
sing all right what you suffer this
pretty
put me down baby what are you doing when
China hide from me bounce get out of it
they're locked to the ground but boss
what is it sorcery hi Caramba
I don't like Oh what is that 10 about
trying to hide from me
tinderboxes can't hide from me maybe the
keys here now now eyes Lucknow it's
going here luck - what about the
basement Japan oh I'll be right there
all right pity I'll look over here I
guess bass oh you are locked then you
get out of here all right you will I
will use you what is up with this place
oh no that's not good well I have a lot
of oil say something hey catch oh god
damn Colossus what are you doing young
no not young what to do ah what is this
what is this it looks like wall-e hi
Perry
Molly Molly what are you trying to kill
me what oh snap ah can a man pick up a
tinder box without you having hey you
got wrong pity you got freaking Trog ha
hell I'd known and then we got a lion
animal at least well that's good
lovely you got scared pity yeah this is
my friend Berta Oh Berta Berta Berta I
had a lot of fun yesterday yeah we did
yeah we'd had fun I like I mean piggy
he's a good husband
what I'm not looking for anything
serious what the hell's wrong with you
but I thought you loved me piggy I love
you but not in that way
alright I'm gonna go with pity and OH
why haven't you introduced us to a new
friend pity he's dead but that doesn't
mean we can't have fun with him right
but the hell are you talking about piggy
you're crazy I mean look at this
doesn't matter if it's dead oh I can
still feel this Oh what is this where's
this we can have a lot of fun fun here
mmm oh yeah all right I just leave them
alone I think
I got a key right I didn't get anything
Berta Berta
I love piggy why would he just leave me
I like to ever that's down there crazy
everyone is crazy I need a key
there we go hey Jesus hello Betty touch
my neck but if you want her of course I
mean I'm here for you if you want to
touch what it says I wrote something
down I need to find a way out of my
house
I'll have to improvise a key I remember
having a needle somewhere in my
experience land alright so I guess the
other door goes to the experimental lab
or whatever which is probably in here ah
[ __ ] me this is a problem and there was
nothing in here I this is probably much
no we can do it I can do it for Sparta
and Lady gaga
my mostly Lady gaga oh I can climb here
oh cool
alright it looks like you and me Jesus
alright I'm glad I mean I want to
connect with you I tried emailing you I
tried using my god powers and like try
to connect with you nothing really
alright we have the key right alright
let's go down there and see what happens
in the basement probably not good things
because Jesus can't come with us I mean
what are we gonna do without him I'm not
much for shuts on mice nestled in so
Fritzl pixel pretzel
oh no oh no
I don't like this how about anyone in
here hey you are drowning lovely
okay what's the share what are you doing
stop mob trying to loot [ __ ] here I
don't think there's anything you know
all right
anyone here a mattress and a poo bucket
lovely absolutely fantastic I love it I
love it big fan huh okay okay all right
hey Oh what is that that what a monster
or anyone splashing and want to splash
with me you splash from my mom what I
don't know why I've said but I said
something all right
sledgehammer what are you doing here I
don't even know anymore okay yes all
right all right
oh I hate the water I hate the water
it's okay that's all right dad if I I'll
tell you doing Jennifer almost had a
ball you
it's okay it's okay having some time
it's all right we're out of the water
it's really cozy I love it big fan all
right what is this
go on so many stairs I should've ate it
put it I shouldn't have ate it so much
oh god I hate so much
hey this is cozy hello
who's in here someone was clearly
looking for something
we got the needle yes I did it but
sparta and lady gaga mostly lady gaga
I love that girl no I don't ok so now we
can go back I guess
Wow go down the stairs go downstairs go
downstairs yeah I did it for me and a
lot of other people too
I mean Stefano I did for two alright so
here we go in here yeah with it ah let's
just strut my way
[Music]
ah
oh my pants are wet now god damn that
got me really [ __ ] oh my god you're
still there the mic like it never falls
the humming I'm glad for you brother
hope that didn't Bob say was your father
back I'm sick of this shut a check of
all this [ __ ] why do you keep harassing
me huh
I okay I'm doing this now I'm gonna make
a deal with it why does it pay day oh
you talk now yes I [ __ ] hate you pity
well I'll hate you everything we do
against you but why why barrel I don't
know I don't like your face
it's not a problem I don't like your
face either pity we don't even have a
face what are you talking about I'm
sorry but yeah I hate you don't get out
of my life
sick of it [ __ ] battle plan [ __ ] you
barrel I will never forgive you
they don't care bow on it is on it's not
on off at least they needs to follow us
but up did you hear this develop where
are you did you hear about this tomorrow
he's gonna be mad just light it up to
make it more cozy I know I left him here
somewhere
Savannah Savannah but is he ah [ __ ] me I
have to go here without him alright
little [ __ ] I hate those cut up there
boss I have a letter Lily Carter ma
caught them off hey what is this I can
pump it I can pump it
okay I can't pump it I wish I could pump
it I wish everything was comfortable
just like your mom
sorry I didn't mean that I'm sorry if
you are a mom then what I won't say
something what I don't think I I think I
have a couple months watching me
I remember now all right it's calm it's
fine
Jennifer I love you penny I got this
present party what are you doing here
Wally Wally I would ever stop hey more
oil I need that whoo buckets get out of
here Oh what ah you loose
what do you want oh it was you wasn't it
all along
ah you're testing me aren't you we hate
you even more now what how can you hate
me oh it was a proofer wasn't it I need
some sort of tool all right I need it to
last us so lattice I toilet
it only oh we're working with the
barrels penny and I saw the official we
hate all right why what did I do
ah I didn't do anything
oh no we got to do in need of water Oh
No Oh No
I promised I would end it here because
I'm [ __ ] terrified in my sweaty and
stuff so I that's usually but I promised
I'd make a little longer episodes and
this is a [ __ ] corridor that's lovely
all right that is brace for impact I
just know something bad is gonna happen
Oh potatoes but tell you doing it why
are you everywhere every [ __ ] video
again you just follow me why I don't get
it
give me my tinder box huh tell me you
spoke before didn't you why don't you
talk now who is your leader
we will never tell you pity huh I will
figure it out don't worry I will find
your leader and I would what the hell
what's going on here what is his hand
here Oh underneath grab that [ __ ] grab
it by the arm he likes it he likes it a
lot Hey I had a feeling there would be
something there
oh no bad loss did you warn him this is
not good [ __ ] you about alright potato
potato
stay with me potato I promise pity I'm
not working with the barrels it's
working without pity you've screwed what
there isn't time bidding Oh No
is he coming in here
alright never mind I'll find someone
like you I mean nothing but their [ __ ]
your skirt is it you're so scared but
don't worry I'll sing to calm you I mean
nothing but their best for you too don't
forget me you're so screwed pay they
holy [ __ ] you're more screwed than your
mom what does that mean goddammit go
away already
I mean it it just calmly sneaked past
I like we get no no it's locked
I'll wait I have the key
alright alright close the door I'm gonna
a hairbrush
thank your favorite cheese you enjoy
subscribe to do coma bro today and
you're into the Burleigh me um yeah
that's pretty much it no one likes you
anyway polish it alright run the
garbanzo Bob like bear baby baby you
betcha
baton back hog by tongue in your faces
right nipple left nipple
Lady Gaga would be proud of me you know
that up